On our eight hour flight last night,
lucky mentioned this amazing half baked cookie
with salted caramel ice cream that he had
and how badly he was craving it.
So this morning I woke up extra early to make him one.
I started by making my salted caramel ice cream
by letting some sugar turn amber
and color, combining that with some heavy cream, milk,
generous pinch of salt, and a little bit more sugar
before letting that warm up and tempering my eggs with it.
Once my eggs were tempered,
I poured them back into the pot,
let that thicken until it coated the back of my spoon,
before straining it through a fine mesh strainer
and setting it in the freezer to chill.
Once it was cold, I turned it in my ice cream maker
and once it hit that soft serve consistency,
I put that in the freezer for about two hours
while I got started on my cookie dough.
Whisk together my sugar and butter,
added my eggs, some egg yolk,
and made sure that was combined before adding my flour,
some cornstarch, and baking soda,
giving that a good mix,
and then roughly chopping my extra dark chocolate
and adding that to the bowl as well
and folding that in until just combined.
I let those bake for just under 10 minutes
since we're going for a very under baked cookie,
and then we were done. I made sure to serve the cookie hot,
put Some of that caramel ice cream on the side,
topped it with some flaky salt and breakfast was done.
Usually doesn't have sweet treats like this,
but he absolutely loved it.